Speaker 1: Hey, this is just beyond parity. Absent
Father Herschel Walker said in August of 2020 or
no, I'm sorry, in August, August 20th of this
year said that you can't have absent fathers.
It's bad when people are absent, Father. He sort
of ran on. I'm going to make sure we don't have
absent fathers. But he's an absent father. It's
absolutely unbelievable. This is an interview
between Herschel Walker and Diamond and silk.
And to be totally honest now, I'm not sure was
this in August of 2020 or August 20th of 2022?
Doesn't matter. Okay. Absent Father Herschel
Walker has a message about absent fatherhood.
Speaker 3: And let's become fathers of those
fatherless. I mean, let's try to direct
them in the right way. Yeah. Yeah. Well.
Speaker 2: I mean, can I just say this here?
Okay. So you raised your child. Now you got
to go and try to be a father to somebody
else. What about teaching our black man
that if you lay down with a woman and you
make a baby, it is our responsibility to
stay there to make sure that this is right.
Speaker 3: Well, that's what I'm talking
about. Give them good values that you have.
Then you say, You know what? Then I say,
this is someone you have a child with at home.
Even if you have to leave that home, even if
you have to leave that moment, you don't leave the
child. Right. Right. You let that child know. You
try to work it out. You got to be respectful
to her. And you're going to be respectful to
other things. You show it to your child. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Now, unfortunately, not following
his own advice. Number one, Herschel
Walker, completely absent as a father
to look. I don't even know how many kids this guy
has, at least absent to some, I believe, two kids.
It's very hard to keep track of. And
also recently denounced by his son,
Christian Walker, you'll remember that multi
commodity, multi tweet screed, which included,
quote, I know my mom and I would really appreciate
it if my father, Herschel Walker, stopped lying
and making a mockery of us. You're not a family
man. When you left us to bang, a bunch of women
threatened to kill us and had us move over six
times in six months running from your violence.
Couldn't he just tell the truth about anything?
Anything? Oh, absent fathers are bad. Well,
he's an absent father. I'm a police officer. No,
he's not. I trained with the FBI. I'm authorized
this way and that way. No, you didn't. I ran some.
What was the business? He claimed he ran and he
did. It's hard to even keep track of the lives.
And the Republican voters don't care because they
either assume that it's fake news that he's lying.
It can't possibly be. Or they straight up say,
listen, Raphael Warnock is a Democrat. I'm not
voting for him. And of course, how could I forget?
Abortion is murder. No exceptions ever. And then
he goes and pays for a woman's abortion after
urging her to get it and then urges her to get
a second abortion, which she declines to do.
Horrifying. We will have this clip on our
Instagram, which you can find at David Pakman show